our next question comes from Tanner H on
YouTube and Tanner writes how do you
edit to build up tension also how is
editing for comedy different than
editing for other genres well you know
the way I in it to build up tension is
to look at the material that the
directors provided for me and follow the
script and try to assemble it in the
most effective way possible you know
it's really hard to say
sometimes the you'll get material that
provides everything for you
you know the cutaways and the reaction
shots on the faces and the camera moves
and things like that and then other
times you won't you'll just get the
camera move you know and maybe it'll be
like a an attempt at a Hitchcockian
thing I really let the film speak to me
you know I I really try to just see what
was recorded and I use my instinct my
years of watching movies and television
to try to make the scene as interesting
as possible now that might be as tense
as possible or as comic as possible now
obviously with you know a suspense
--fill scene or you know something like
that
music is a huge factor so as good as my
cut might be and hopefully it's good
putting the right piece of music in
there and the right sound effects are
gonna have a tremendous impact on on the
effectiveness of the scene so it's not
just picture cutting you know it's it's
just it's it's looking at the material
that was delivered to you sometimes
depending on the relationship you have
with it
director if you think they're missing
something you can go and ask them for
that you can say you know it might be
nice to get a shot of the hand reaching
to the doorknob now a lot of young
editors might be afraid to do that a lot
of editors who have a first-time
relationship where the director might be
afraid to do that sometimes you go to
the DP and you say hey what do you think
wouldn't it be great if we got this cut
away if you don't have a good
relationship or a trust fold you know
sort of like mature or not mature but
you know developed a relationship with
the director I I mean it depends on you
know how bad you think you need that
piece sometimes it's better to just shut
your mouth and not say anything
depending on the situation but you you
know again go with your gut go with your
instinct what do you think is the most
tense and then music and effects you
know will help bring it to I believe you
know you know the next level in terms of
comedy similar kind of answer what makes
you laugh what do you think is funny you
know on your initial editor's cut and
again that's the only kind of
perspective I can bring them because
that's the you know I'm not working for
an independent you know with a director
in the room from the very beginning I'm
assembling the film as they're shooting
it so basically I look at the stuff I
see what makes me laugh and I try to
figure out how to make that work the
challenging part isn't so much that as
it is with improv comedy you'll get
three or four versions and they're all
funny they're all good but you can
really only get one in the scene or the
scene will go on forever so it's kind of
like what's funniest what's best for the
scene and again this is where having
sort of different people's opinions and
takes
on the material come in really handy you
know and and you know quite often you'll
you'll come to a consensus with the
producer and the director and you know
it's it's it's usually not one person
saying this is the funniest you know
you're all idiots almost sometimes you
in fact more than you'd believe but you
know a lot of times it's like you know
what's working best here and you go with
your instinct but it's gonna change its
invariably gonna change many many times
during the process you know you'll have
your version you'll cut the directors
version you'll you know you know you'll
cut four or five more different versions
of the directors version you'll pull
something out of your bin that you did
as an alternate into the directors
version the producer will come in and
mix all that up it's it's completely
malleable until it gets shipped to the
studio that's anything
you